the government and NHS leaders have made
it a top priority to cut elective care
waiting times but today's numbers paint
a mixed picture despite prioritizing the
service overall waiting lists have
reached a new record of
7.33 million that's up a hundred and ten
thousand the biggest month-on-month
increase since August last year
a key NHS Target was to eliminate
18-month weights by April that has been
missed but they are getting close in
September 2021 there were almost 125
000 patients waiting a year and a half
that is now down to almost 10 000.
half of those remaining are at just 10
NHS trusts the NHS says part of the
reason for missing targets is the
unprecedented industrial action seen
over the past six months
we've had to reschedule around 500 000
appointments over the period of all the
industrial action that has taken place
but the important thing about today's
figures is that thanks to the hard work
of NHS staff we have reduced the number
of people who've been waiting more than
18 months for treatment by 90 there is
also some good news for cancer Services
the number of people waiting more than
two months to start treatment is down to
almost a third compared with more than
41 in February but but before 2019 that
figure had not exceeded 17 percent
there is also an alarming rise in
children's waiting lists while 18-month
weights are continuing to be reduced the
number waiting for a year are at the
highest since records began in April
2021.
the figures have Amplified calls for the
Urgent release of a long-awaited
Workforce plan with trust leaders
warning that without it the NHS will
continue to struggle to meet
ever-growing Demand with too few staff